i'm sure that some of you have heard the
word manichaean before
it is often a word used for something
that is strongly
dualistic or lacks nuance but
some of you may also know that it was an
ancient religion that flourished in the
middle east and in the
central asian region particularly in
fact manichaeism was once one of the
most
widespread and popular religions in the
world
and has been called by scholars the
first world religion
but not many people know too much about
this faith
tradition so let's change that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
our information about the religion of
manichaeism is pretty sparse
prior to the 20th century all the
information we had basically came from
secondary sources
you may have heard about manichaeism for
example from the writings of
augustine one of the most famous early
christian theologians who actually
was a manichaean before he converted to
christianity
there is also writings by later muslim
writers like
alberoni but none of these texts are
very reliable because of their very
polemical nature because
all of these texts especially those by
christian writers are
highly critical of manichaeism and is
political in the way that they are
trying to discredit the religion in
favor of
christianity as they understood it but
by the 20th century archaeologists
started to discover
sites and documents that have helped us
enormously
in understanding this religion in a more
direct way
excavations in central asia in the oasis
of turfan or in madinat madi or kellis
in
egypt have uncovered texts or places of
worship and other very valuable material
what emerges from these finds is a
religion that is complex and unique and
yet is strongly connected to other
movements in these regions at the time
okay so let's get to it what is or was
manichaeism
let's start at the beginning the
beginning of this story centers around
the religion's
main figure and prophet mani he was most
likely born in 216 of the common era
in a city close to the tigris rivers it
was close to modern-day baghdad
this region was part of the larger
sassanian persian empire at the time and
was an
incredibly multicultural and vibrant
environment
in terms of religion it was a melting
pot of different
both old and new emerging traditions
zoroastrianism was of course very strong
as it was the
kind of official religion state religion
of the sasanian empire and of course had
a huge
influence but we also find different
jewish groups
mandaeans and new movements that had
formed around the figure of jesus of
nazareth what we
today know as christianity the
christians was not a unified group
at this point but consisted of many
different individual movements
some of which were still very strongly
connected to judaism while others were
starting to
increasingly separate from it there was
also a strong presence of buddhism at
this time especially in these central
asian regions so you can see
there were many different religious
movements it was a very vibrant
time so mani grew up in this kind of
environment this incredibly
multi-religious multicultural
environment
and this would of course have a strong
influence on his later religious
teachings
he has sometimes been portrayed as a
persian prophet and thus being
foreign to the judeo-christian or
abrahamic framework
but this is actually highly inaccurate
in fact for the first two decades of his
life following in his father's footsteps
mani belonged to a jewish christian
group called the elkicites
this group apparently put a large
emphasis on purification rituals perhaps
similar to the mandaeans as well as many
other
jewish and christian groups at this time
but mani was destined for
other things as he started receiving
revelations
at the age of 12 and then at 24
resulting in him leaving the elkicites
and instead starting his own
religious movement after this he would
spend the rest of his life doing
very heavy missionary work in all across
the persian empire as well as the roman
empire for a while he also traveled to
india and became quite
popular there even according to some
reports being called
buddha by some people one very
significant thing about mani which
sets him apart from a lot of the other
founders or main figures of different
religions
is that he actually wrote down a lot of
texts
this was apparently a conscious effort
to avoid making that same mistake as
others
had done like the buddha or jesus who
didn't write
themselves and so he wanted to write
many different books
in order that there would be no
misunderstandings by later followers now
of course you could argue that it's
impossible for understandings to appear
anyway but it is also
said that mani was a great artist or
painter and indeed
visual art would come to play an
important part in the maniki and
religion as we will see
now somewhere around the year 242 mani
while
back in persia successfully preached his
message and actually received the
support of the sitting sasanian king
shah puri the first this allowed mani
and his followers to spread even further
and wider
as an endorsement from the king made
things significantly easier of course
and what manny preached was a unique and
universal religion he saw himself as the
heir to great prophets like jesus
zarathustra and the buddha and his
new religion as the pure or true
versions the most pure
form of these religions that is
christianity
zoroastrianism and buddhism but above
all
mani describes himself as an apostle of
jesus and his connection to jesus was
particularly strong and significant
connected to this is also the fact that
mani was identified as the so-called
paraclete which is mentioned in the new
testament in the gospel of john also
sometimes called the helper
the paraclete is according to many
christian readings associated or
identified with the holy spirit
but it should not be understood that
manny saw himself or was
identified with the holy spirit in the
sense of being part of the trinity
the doctrine of the trinity was not
firmly established in christianity at
this time
and the manikins did not adhere to this
doctrine
but seeing himself as the heir to these
great prophets and preaching a religion
that was supposedly the
pure version of these other major
religions
mandy would often present his religion
in a way that was very approachable and
and easy to understand for the local
population so he could
speak to the local population and and
claim that their
local tradition was often in harmony
with his own
which was of course a very effective way
of missionary work of spreading his
faith
so in the teachings of manichaeism we
find
many aspects of different religions that
were popular in this region
at the time there are very strong
influences from
biblical and abrahamic sources of course
but also very clear references to ideas
in zoroastrianism as well as in buddhism
it also appears that the form that
manichaeism took in different regions
depended somewhat
on the sort of major religious
traditions in that particular region so
manichaeism like all other religions is
of course
or was constantly changing and evolving
depending on
new times and places new cultural
contexts
and so we can see that uh manichaeism in
the more western parts of its spread in
the sort of roman empire the western
middle east and north africa
take on a much more sort of
judeo-christian or jewish christian form
while in the central asian region the
zoroastrian and
buddhist influences are a lot more
pronounced
but mani's support by the sasanian king
was temporary
as soon as shapoor died and after the
short reign of his successor hormuz the
first
the king bharam took the throne and
things started to change
significantly the zoroastrian clergy had
been strongly critical of
mani and his movement and called for
very harsh measures against them
the new king ended official support for
manichaeism
and a great persecution started here
manny himself was actually arrested and
put in prison
in the year either 276 or 277
and some sources claim that after only
26 days
he succumbed to the terrible conditions
in prison
and died this marked the end of the life
of the prophet mani but by no means was
this the end of
the religion that he started he had been
very successful he and his followers
at spreading the religion into different
parts of the world and this only
continued after he died
it spread across the middle east to
north africa
and even spain it's paired to georgia
central asia
india and all the way to china by the
year 400 a bit
more than a hundred years after mani's
death there were many keen communities
in syria
palestine egypt arabia armenia
rome and spain just to mention a few
in a very short amount of time the
religion had managed to spread to
basically every corner of the known
world
a feat that no other religion had
managed before
now this is why some scholars have
referred to manichaeism
as the first world religion in history
you can see why
this may be the case but manichaeism for
most of its history remained under very
strong
persecution in persia and central asia
they were strongly oppressed by the
zoroastrian clergy and by
the persian kings the religion was
basically forbidden
and in the west the developing
christianity became also increasingly
critical of the manikins
and once they were in power they would
of course strongly persecute them as
well
to the christian polemical writers the
manikins were either seen as a foreign
persian religion that had invaded the
christian lands
or it was seen as a heretical movement
within christianity itself
neither of which was very good news
interestingly evidence from kellis in
egypt one of the archaeological sites
shows that there have been time periods
when the manichaeans and
christians these are mainstream
christians lived side by side and
that the manikins if given the question
would have most likely identified
themselves as
christian this shows us that things are
a lot more complex than what is often
assumed
the religious identity of the
manichaeans is a complicated question
that can't be explained in very simple
terms we
shouldn't as many have done simply say
that manichaeism is a form of christian
gnosticism
because not only is gnosticism itself an
arbitrary term that wasn't necessarily a
unified community at all
but manichaeism was also very different
in significant
ways to the theology expressed in those
texts we often refer to
as gnostic even if there are many
interesting similarities of course too
the great persecution that the manikins
faced in basically every part of the
world that it existed
is one of the reasons that the religion
is basically extinct today
things got a little easier after the
arab conquest and under the early
islamic caliphates but there were
periods of persecution here as well
so even though the religion had appeared
and spread in a very
rapid pace and spread to large parts of
the world
in just a few centuries it had all but
disappeared
by the 11th century the religion had
more or less died out in the middle
east in persia and north africa it did
however survive
in southern china for a few more
centuries some say until around the 17th
century but since then it's been pretty
quiet
it is very possible that there have been
small communities surviving there is for
example a group
on the website reddit where people
interested in manichaeism gather
and it appears that there are some still
practicing it today to some degree
so there may very well be people who
still identify as
manichaeans but there are so few of them
that we can
still basically call the religion
extinct and even if the religion itself
isn't necessarily around anymore it
probably has had a great
impact on other religions other cultures
being such a widely spread and popular
religion in the late ancient
period it must have in some way
influenced the other currents that were
happening at the time including of
course christianity
islam also developed in a region and
time when manichaeism was very much
present
and so we can speculate also as to how
much manichaism
may have influenced that religion too
it's interesting that mani is said to
have called himself the seal of the
prophets much like what the quran calls
the prophet muhammad
but this comes from later muslim writers
so we should
probably take this with a grain of salt
but this leads us to that central
question that most of you have probably
been asking yourself since the start of
this video
what did the manikins believe and how
did they practice
their religion as i've already mentioned
mani saw himself as a
universal prophet he was the heir to
zarathustra to the buddha and above all
to
jesus so when we look at the beliefs of
manikiasin
we find traces of all of these different
religions one of the main characteristic
features of the manichaean theology and
cosmology
is a very strong dualism the religion is
so strongly associated with dualism that
the word manikin has become a kind of
shorthand word for anything that is
strongly dualistic
even outside of the sphere of religion
but what this means on a religious level
is that manny and his followers saw the
world as
consisting of two essential forces that
of light or
good and that of darkness or evil this
is of course similar to some forms of
christianity like what we call
gnosticism but in particular there are
strong similarities here
with zoroastrianism and just like in
zoroastrianism the manichaeans divide
world history into
three stages in the first stage
light and darkness are completely
separated spheres
god or the father of greatness rules
over the sphere of light which consists
of his attributes like
purity light strength wisdom and the
five elements of light
water fire air and wind
the sphere of darkness is ruled by the
king of darkness and his
five offspring here we also find five
elements
smoke darkness fire water and wind
the second phase or era of creation is
when the dark and light spheres come
into contact the darkness wants to
infiltrate the
light but the father of greatness
creates the
mother of life so called who in turn
sends
original man which is a kind of
spiritual form of man
to infiltrate the sphere of darkness and
destroy it
from the inside like a trojan horse if
you will
once the king of darkness and his
offspring are defeated
original man together with the mother of
life create the universe from the bodies
of these dark beings
and the light that original man had
sneakily placed within them
so as a result the universe that we know
consists both of the stuff
of darkness that is the bodies of these
dark beings which is mainly the material
aspect of the world
and also the stuff of light things like
the human soul or the planets and stars
in the sky
for the rest of the second phase and
into the third
phase which is the current one the
purpose of this whole existence
is to separate the light from its dark
material
in order to hopefully reach a complete
separation of the two once again
this has been the purpose of all the
previous prophets jesus
buddha zarathustra and now finally mani
to remind humanity of the true source of
the light
in order that they may neglect their
material body
and all other aspects of life cons that
is connected to the forces of darkness
okay are you with me so far this is
obviously a very
complicated cosmology even i have
trouble uh keeping it all together
sometimes but this is the basic idea
behind
the dualism of the manichaeans the world
is like a cleaning factory to separate
the particles of
light from the darkness and in the
practices of this religion we find
traces of this scheme
in the microcosm of the human being the
same struggle takes place as in the
macrocosm of the cosmos so this means
that we as human beings must
also struggle to separate the light
particles from the darkness within
ourselves
since manichaeism has a rather negative
attitude towards the
human the body and the material world in
general as they are seen as being made
from the stuff of darkness
the rules and and practices of the
manichaeans
may seem to be very strict mani
instructed people to live very ascetic
lives to not lie never kill any living
being and to practice pacifism
not to eat any meat not to drink alcohol
and to live in complete celibacy
abstaining from all
sexual and reproductive activity now as
strict as this may
sound it must be pointed out that not
all manikins were required to follow
these rules
instead the community was divided into
two general groups
the elect and the hearers the elect were
those who had taken the manikin vows and
followed all the above rules very
strictly
as well as praying and fasting very
intensely
their entire lives were dedicated to
separating the light from darkness
through
their ascetical practice now the hearers
on the other hand were kind of
lay people they weren't required to
follow these rules to the letter they
could eat meat
as long as they had not killed the
animal themselves they could for example
also have sex within the context of a
marriage and therefore also have
children
but even though the rules weren't as
strict for these hearers
they were still encouraged to follow
them as much as they could
having children for example was
technically allowed but it was
considered ideal to not have them
as having children would continue the
cycle of
the material darkness aside from these
rules all mannequins were also required
to pray on a daily basis
a number of prayers is very hard to tell
but it seems that it may have been
three prayers a day maybe four prayers a
day
the times of day when the prayers took
place is also
basically impossible to know for sure
but it seems that the manikins may have
adopted
to the mainstream practice or the the
most prominent practice in
a certain region so for example in later
periods when the manikins lived under
muslim rule the prayer times may have
been
sort of adjusted to to sync up with the
prayer times of the muslims
the swedish scholar of religion jurgen
magnusson has written an article on the
food practices of the manikins
which serves as an interesting example
of how the relationship between the
elect and the hearers
functioned and also gives us a look into
some of the practices of the community
in general
since the elect were to live strictly
pure lives they were forbidden from
using
any kind of violence even violence
against plants or vegetation
this made it basically impossible for
them to provide themselves with any food
so instead
during their daily meal the hearers
would provide them
with the vegetarian food in a kind of
ritual
the elect would then pray and bless the
food and the person bringing
it which cleared the hearer from the
charge of having used violence to get
them the food
and then through their meal and their
congestion system
the elect within because they lived such
holy and pure lives
released the light particles of the food
from the dark
and thus serve the cause of the world of
light through this ritual meal
so this meal or table was a kind of
exchange
the hearers brought food to the elect
and was forgiven for their sins as a
result
and the elect themselves used the food
and meal as a way
to help separate the light from the
darkness
this is just a short summary and a few
examples of the
practices of the manichaeans of course
research and scholarship
is giving us more information as time
goes by
another somewhat characteristic aspect
of manichaeism is their prominent
art visual art there are plenty of
surviving manichaean depictions of
various scenes and cosmological schemes
that are
quite beautiful and dramatic the
manikins used both the written word
and visual art to convey its religious
message
which is probably why we find so many
examples like this
if you remember it is also said that
manny himself was a great
an accomplished painter and artist so
there may be a connection here as well
sadly as i've said manichaeism is
basically extinct today
but it survives through the discoveries
and information that archaeologists and
scholars are
bringing to light as well as through the
influence that manichaeism may have had
on religious traditions that survived to
this day it is a religion that can teach
us a lot about the ancient middle east
and a religious context that was
incredibly vibrant and
influential if you want me to make more
videos about manichaeism and
explore in detail some of its more
particular aspects
please let me know in the comments
because this is a fascinating subject to
research i would love
to do some further work on it page and
time
i would like to thank some of our new
additions to the patreon community
neural allen and luke burns thank you
both
so much your support is of course highly
helpful
if you want to become a patron of this
channel i will leave a link
to the patreon page in the description
you can check out the different
tiers and and options and and make a
decision for yourself
i hope this video was a good and
interesting introduction to manichaeism
as i said if you want more then let me
know in a comment
and if you want to support this channel
you can as i mentioned you can become a
patron
or you can simply like the video or
subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you